something we don't see very often with
these videos but I do hope we get more
soon we have a tablet and it's none
other than the Samsung Galaxy Tab S9
Ultra and we're gonna put it through the
gaming Gauntlet of Genji impact honkai
style Cod mobile and pubg mobile and see
how well it performs and this thing is
it's huge can I even get it in the
screen goddamn performance wise the
Samsung Galaxy Tab S9 Ultra 5G that we
are using has a Snapdragon agent too and
adrenal 740 for its GPU 12 gigs of RAM
256 gigs of storage and everything plays
out only 120hz Dynamic AMOLED 14.6 inch
screen with a 11 200 million power
battery that's a lot of battery before
you run the test let's do a baseline of
the temperatures of the front and back
of the tablet
so we're looking at 26.7 27 inch at the
top here in the middle as we go down 27
inch across the board also we are
currently at 100 battery so let's see
all right pretty uniform all the way
let's check the back
27 inch at the top okay still pretty
much in line with the temperatures on
the front let's keep going down
nothing out of the ordinary just 27
degrees Celsius okay so with that let's
get into our first game
honkustarial
alright so now they're in Hong Kong
stereo let's just check things out and
let's check out set things real quick
settings
all right so everything's on very high
60 FPS and I think things are looking
pretty good
so with that let's just see how the
camera moves
there's no family jump shot server
nothing is really bringing this game so
far let's see each apart real quick and
he looks really good at the screen damn
all right let's just do quick change
this area
apart that's the sample all right things
are looking pretty good
okay I think we're set let's just enter
the simulative universe
[Music]
let's just get this light out real quick
so let's just turn this off for now just
over that all right let's just go for
balance
it's looking pretty good oh nice I mean
we are way too overpowered but I just
want to keep the using low running for
now to keep some double consistency
first
okay okay we're doing good we're doing
good thanks
all right my turn
nice all right let's go for a break
lost there we go back to Portugues
nice okay
all right let's just keep walking
towards that meat man can we need a
strategy it's cool we're doing a
strategies
let's go
all right now let's get those shoes
come on can we smooth I guess
yeah that's super smooth nice
here we go
[Music]
yeah all right
here okay
come on just a bit more oh okay we got
Shields
nice oh boy
yeah we're almost there
all right
we shall never fall
[Music]
try this other side
bam
oh and we're so close to being this
guy
all right I think we should be with you
yep and we're done nice
so before we get into respite let's just
check our temperatures real quick
temperature game we are at 38 oh okay
that's heating up quite a bit 35
33 35 again
in the arrow yeah okay it's heating up
not not as much actually I've seen worse
but 38 around here I guess this is where
the processor is at but honestly it does
not feel like it's a 38 right now
so with that let's check the back real
quick
so far no major feeling drops I haven't
seen any frame stuff doing up any sort
it's having the game pretty well the
Samsung S9 Galaxy Tab Ultra
all right let's check the back
86.8 funny enough it's 36 here but it's
not 38 on here all right but still
doing a pretty good job pretty nice
where is it
what
okay that may happen
but never mind let's keep moving on 38
around here somewhere
all right and then nothing still it's
still all right I mean given it's Hong
Kai style it's a pretty intensive game
but with that let's keep moving let's
move on
two no no no no no no no no you don't
want to exit
it's just more than a boss
you don't even strategy single back then
let's go
nice all right let's activate everything
and the kitchen sink
[Laughter]
for two
all right welcome
[Music]
very quickly now
all right let's go off here what are you
waiting for to betray my customers
my charge extra
nice we're so close to finishing this up
apart
and
tough luck running into me okay me too
if that's what's possible
all right let's wet
rules are made to be broken
look
it's one down one more to go
I don't know what I'm gonna do but never
mind let's just get these shoes up okay
reserve's not done yet okay never
filtered you're so close
look
all right now
all right reckonies
you're so close
nice okay sick and with that we've come
to the end of Hawkeye starter let's
check temperatures really quickly
all right 34 39 out here honestly it
does not feel like it's 39
and let's check continue checking 37 35
you're doing pretty good all right okay
38 down here all right nothing too crazy
kind of expected to be honest I mean we
do something once again let's check the
back
it doesn't feel that warm it's still
pretty cool to touch except
unfortunately with this area down here
that's probably where the processor is
at but other than that it's
it's doing pretty well
all right 39 right here oh almost 40
somewhere on here
almost 40 here let's keep going
and yeah all right
pretty good stuff Samsung and with that
it's going to our next game against it
impact so we are hot off the heels of
honkai stereo let's just check them but
just real quick we are currently at 96
and let's go down
29 28 everything has more or less gone
down a little bit from the initial
readings that we had at the end of the
game place I shouldn't and yeah let's
check the back
28.6
all right and 29.2 and 28.7 all right
everything is looking pretty okay
all right all right okay nothing's even
going on with that dude this thing
dissipates heat pretty well and with
that let's move on to the engine impact
yeah so another in the game let's just
check settings real quick set things
and Graphics okay so everything's at the
highest 60 FPS everything is turned on
all right cool now because again I'm
gonna need to hold this up a little bit
but before we do that let's just see our
character in the details and as you can
see yeah
something pretty damn good look at that
some nice shadows and everything as you
can see the rendering distance is pretty
far out
and even with the Securus and everything
falling there are no huge freeway drops
or anything what's on whatsoever let's
just do a quick character change
[Music]
all right no fury drops and let's just
move him around the camera is looking
pretty good all right so with that let's
just run through the city and see if
there any other drops and
I have to say that this thing is the tab
is huge that's one thing that's that's a
day I'm sure
all right these are rendering in right
now
and with that let's keep moving and
so far I haven't seen okay A bit of
frame stuff during here in them and
things are still rendering in
okay cool
let's just keep going
I mean it's still quite bearable it
isn't bad or anything and it's not
completely failing so this is a pretty
good start fog engine impact
and
that was all right
but let's just see how exploration and
maybe a little bit of combat will work
with the tab
[Applause]
all right so now that we're out here not
much very drops and it's looking pretty
smooth
it's oh the engine looks beautiful in
this thing okay A little bit of frame
and stuff during the
but it's oof look at this
there looks great
and then let's just get into some combat
let's keep moving
yeah
all right
this is doing ulti real quick
foreign
it's a bit hard to move around
I mean given that this is
not exactly beautiful so I think you're
throwing your control for this thing
it's not the most practical if I'm being
honest
yep I can't really get to the buttons
that I want to
all right
[Music]
oh God
here we go
[Music]
yeah here we go keep going
let's go for another
let's go for an adult real quick
all right hopefully we can get you down
[Music]
oh boy okay nice I think one more guy
somewhere on here
where are you
oh there you are
combat everything looks pretty good I
haven't seen any major family drops a
bit of frame starting here and there but
the thing is if you're playing big games
like this the tab is pretty huge so it's
not super practical but if you had a
game controller I think that would fix
most of the issues so exploration and
combat outside so far pretty alright
nothing major and with that let's just
go into the spiral a bit and see how it
handles multiple enemies
[Applause]
composition I think it's terrible but we
are going to get through this look at
that all through real quick
don't waste my time actually
there we go
all right shouldn't let your guard down
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
nice okay so things are looking pretty
up for this thing I mean honestly no
huge family jumps whatsoever
so
yes let's just keep going
and I missed that completely nice
[Music]
oh that's cute let's go this one will be
Frozen in Time
let's go
yep
there you go things are looking pretty
good oh yeah
and there you have it
let's check temperatures
[Music]
Okay so
uh 33 at the top here okay we're doing
pretty all right so far between 9 30 not
as high as I expect to be but actually
this tab is doing really well right now
try and find that okay can't find it now
still 30 on there 30 31 29.5 and yeah
practicality of play a game like this
onto the huge screen I mean you can do
that if you have a controller I think
they'll make things even better but I
think that performance wise it handles
it pretty well and with that let's move
to the next game Call of Duty mobile
before we get into the next game this
channel is supported by Brands who help
us improve our content and keep us going
so stay around for this sponsored
message meet the Cyber 15 gaming laptop
from MSI check out this translucent
material design that not only looks good
but feels good thanks to its Ultra
lightweight chassis at only 1.98
kilograms give yourself the upper Edge
in gaming with its blazing fast
performance powered by the latest 12th
gen Intel Core i7 HC use processor and
Nvidia RTX 4000 series gpus and stay
immersed with its nahibi twin speaker
sound system that provides an auditory
Feast like no other for more details
check out msi.com okay so we heard of
the heels of the engine impact let's
check the front 31 31 31 30 some of the
best temperatures I've seen so far
and yeah nothing too drastic nothing too
crazy as of yet a lot better than a lot
of the other phones and even gaming
phones that I've tried let's check the
back
3.9 31.9 32 32 around here
I mean yeah q31 and
yeah it's looking pretty good so with
that let's click Call of Duty mobile
and as some of you have requested we'll
be playing the battle rail mode instead
of multiplayer so now in the main menu
the major is looking good as always look
at that
see how the light bounces off her hair
and her jacket looks really good but
before we get into the game let's check
our settings okay settings wise we are
in very high for graphic quality frame
rate is on max
Battle Royale mode everything is turned
on so with that let's just get into a br
match
all right so so far no favorite starting
whatsoever but we need to see how the
tablet will perform once we actually
jump off
pretty good
animations
all right so far let's see
nice
[Music]
what was that I have no idea let's check
where we're gonna go
[Music]
nice so as we are going there let's just
to be honest quickly as we can
go
all right so even the details on my
parachute and everything with all the
animation stuff it's looking pretty good
I just need to get down but still as
quickly as possible
why so we're back in
just need to find out what is all this
textures and anything going on here okay
it's something with the game
it definitely has to do with the game
not really the tab but yeah
anyway let's keep moving
all right where am I getting shot from
all behind
okay let it go off before he try to hit
yeah okay
all right let's keep going we need to
fight some shelter and some guns really
quickly
where is this guy oh there you go
okay so as you can see it's not the
easiest thing to do with to control
guns
come on
[Applause]
oh my God
okay this is why this is exactly why I
have that
oh my God these dogs
okay that's done
and we have a lot of resources now
everything's looking pretty good
all right
we are fine I have no idea what event is
doing right now
okay let's go
okay I think it's looking pretty up
okay don't need that
[Music]
what even is that sound
what is going on
oh boy
okay at least he's down
thank you
half of the teams are eliminated all
right nice
[Applause]
[Music]
oh boy okay that's back we need to run
you
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
wait how many people are there now what
nice and we won
okay so with that
let's check Final temperatures as well
and also we are turning at 86 battery
all right between 8.9 35 okay this one
is heating up pretty quite a bit more
than genshin which is surprising
yeah 33.5 to the 4.9 You've Got High
readings here against the engage in all
honkai style that's interesting
Okay so
again here's about like 37
oh yeah you know but things it doesn't
feel hot it doesn't even feel warm at
all it's just a little bit a little bit
warmer but it's still pretty much cool
to the touch and let's check here
2.3
5 here 34
and
yeah all right
the tab is doing it well the tab is
performing well so with that let's just
get into our final game pubg mobile all
right we are hot off the heels of Call
of Duty mobile let's check temperatures
real quick we're 86 still
27.9 28 this thing has cooled down quite
a bit all right 27 okay nothing too
gnarly let's check the back
and
27.7.00 everything is looking A-Okay
yeah wow this thing really handles heat
pretty damn well and with that let's
just get into our final game pubg mobile
all right so we are at the start screen
let's just check the settings real quick
all right so for our settings we are in
smooth Graphics right now extreme frame
rate and four times anti-aliasing
Everything's looking good let me just
bump up that audio real quick these are
some really good speakers and with that
let's just get into a game
everything looks alright my character
looks really good I'm just trying to get
her around and yeah as you can see how
the light is bouncing off a jacket it's
looking pretty good all right so we have
to see what happens when we drop off
okay so you want that is looking good
everything looks fine no major feeling
drops of course these things only that
sweet snapdriver each and two let's wait
for drop off
all the way down
okay about three quarters of the way
there we're gonna be changing direction
real quick in about
out okay I'll be close but now
all right we'll hit it all right if it
goes up nice
enough Hang Time with the
parachute we're going to be landing on
that rooftop right here
let's get on point
sick and we have a lot of things going
on right now
okay again this thing is pretty huge so
do bear with me here nice keep going
that's right
[Applause]
there we go
hey that's my kill
oh
all right this one down
even more very very busy round but so
far no big Fury drops everything is
moving pretty smoothly
let's see if we can get some crossbow
action
[Applause]
I'm standing still
here we go nice lots of kills
[Music]
nice
to come down
[Music]
[Applause]
where's the fire coming from I see him
assume
nice it's one down
[Music]
nice
and I'm pretty for you
and uh yeah everyone's dead
thank you
oh they're hot they're hot
okay this window
okay
man all right okay that's great okay so
while we're down let's do a oh we're all
down nice except for green over there
who is like
halfway across the map but never mind
let's just check the temperatures real
quick and yeah
so we're at 34 I guess heating up quite
a bit here 33.9 32
okay and nothing out of the ordinary but
also nothing too gnarly so we're
actually doing pretty all right with
temperatures here let's check the back
real quick and put some light on this
right here
all right
so I'm here from the top sorry
32.7 yeah nothing exceeding 35.
yeah this is this is telling him pretty
well man all right all right
so I think
um somehow we're still alive
with that I believe
we can
go to our final thoughts
oh finally
the Samsung Galaxy Tab S9 Ultra 5G
performs really well and its large size
is more than perfect for heat
dissipation any generous screen size for
mobile gaming with the tech and spec it
has it runs all the games we played with
very little hiccups along the way only
thing I will say is that this thing is
huge and long term sessions wouldn't be
kind to your gaming hands you could
shift around the buttons for the
individual games of course but in the
long run I'd suggest getting a separate
controller so you can truly enjoy the
tap in all its Glory if you have any
questions about the Samsung Galaxy Tab
S9 Ultra 5G leave them in the comment
section below and if you like what we do
make sure to follow us on all of our
socials right here and maybe leave a
like and hit that subscribe button it
goes a long way in helping out the
channel if you want to see more stuff
check this out
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]